I think that in order for us to truly
change we have to get Beyond ourselves
and that is one of the Arts of
transformation and with the moment we
are completely in the present moment we
cannot be running a program it turns out
coincidentally when we're truly in the
present moment all possibilities in the
quantum field exist in the Eternal now
so when we're truly present and we take
our attention off our body that's the
moment we become pure Consciousness and
where we place our attention is where we
place our energy so then the moment we
become nobody that's the moment we get
Beyond ourselves is that act of being in
the present moment that allows us to see
new possibilities that we could never
see from the place where we are stuck in
our own programs and personality the act
of doing that is a skill and it requires
feedback feedback happens in a couple
ways one way you get feedback is to
begin to measure the changes you see in
your life this process if it was easy
everybody would be doing it and yet we
are piercing a vowel where p people are
waking up and they're beginning to take
their power back we already innately
know how to do this all we have to do is
keep practicing until we start seeing
those wonderful wonderful feedback
mechanisms happening in our life the
moment you start seeing those changes
taking place in your life you are going
to pay attention to what you did to
cause it the moment you pay attention to
the cause of that action you're no
longer thinking that it's something out
there that did it you're beginning to
realize it's what you did inside of you
to produce it that's when we begin to
take our power back the key to enjoying
your life is being present the key to
focusing is being present the key to
feeling like you're valuable and what
you do matters is being present being
present is at the core to a lot of great
things but a lot of people really
struggle to stay present because what
are you doing most people spend most of
their time
either thinking about the past
or thinking about the future and not
even in a positive way you spend time
thinking about the past living in regret
of all the things that you could have
done you could have said you should have
done you should have said I wish I did
that I wish that video I made didn't
suck you know I wish I wish I wish I
wish why didn't I and we beat ourselves
up does that sound familiar is that you
maybe even a little a little bit or we
spend our time being anxious about the
future
I think as entrepreneurs we get excited
about the future of where we could go
and what we could build and that's
that's the fun daydreaming part but a
lot of thinking about the future is
stress inducing it's anxiety it's it
worrying about what could go wrong all
the millions of things that could go
wrong that may never go wrong but we're
still worried about them right again
does that sound somewhat familiar when
you are stuck living in the past or
living in the future you're never
obviously present but you're not happy
you're not productive you're not focused
you're not creating you're not serving
none of it and you're not fulfilled
I look at people who want to get started
on YouTube for example or entrepreneurs
are trying to launch their business
and
people made maybe one video or two
videos and because it didn't work out
you made a video and you felt
embarrassed by yourself or you launched
a product and somebody had one bad piece
of feedback if we live in that same
negativity over and over and over and
over and over again
people ask me well what happens when you
have a bad video what happens when your
video bombs I was speaking at Brendan
burchard's influencer Summit yesterday
and
somebody asked me what do you do when a
video doesn't take off or do well like
lots of my videos don't take off and do
well
I don't know which ones are gonna blow
up the ones that have blown up surprise
me like that's the one that blew up I
love this one so much more
how do I keep going because I'm looking
to the next one like I'm I'm worried I'm
working on videos now I don't know what
I released yesterday or the day before
the day before
because I'm making new content
think about how you got over a
relationship well you when you get into
a new relationship it's easy to forget
about your last relationship it's
thinking about what you're doing now
and if you have nothing right now what
do you do if there's nothing to do right
now you spend your time in regret about
the past or worried about the future
it's not enough action happening right
now I don't care about videos that
failed in the past because I'm going to
be making tons more another one comes
out today and another one tomorrow
another one tomorrow and it's it's a
moment to reflect and say hey okay I
could have done better on that one or
why didn't this one do well okay this
moment here that sucked perfect I'm
making one today I'll make it better
at least that's the intent maybe I don't
achieve it but that's the intent and we
show up with that intent every day you
will eventually make it better
most people get too caught up on on the
mistakes that they made in the past it's
in the past
you did the best you could with what
you've got remind yourself of that you
did the best you could
with what you had
great don't be so hard on yourself keep
making
because the worst thing you can do is
quit now the worst thing you do is stop
now because when you look back on your
life when you're 120 that you'll regret
that you you stopped you regret that you
had a chance you had a moment
you could have done something and you
didn't like that's the biggest regret of
all
not taking any kind of action not the
mistakes that you made you we don't
regret really the things that we did
most of the things that people regret
are the things they did not do
most people's biggest regrets are not
taking enough action
letting that little man voice inside
their head
tell them all the reasons why they
weren't going to win
convincing themselves that they weren't
capable
and as a result they stopped when they
wish they had the courage the strength
the tenacity to keep going
right that could be you you could you
could you could get going you keep going
you could stay present you could make
the next thing
and at the same time A lot of people are
then also worried about the future
well what if I make this and it doesn't
work out I
was talking to people again yesterday
about their YouTube channels and the
same person asked me
well what if it
doesn't work out
like what if I make videos and nobody
sees them so what if nobody sees my
videos and then the next question was
what if people see my videos and they
don't like me
so this person at the same time is
afraid of people not seeing their videos
and people seeing their videos
so how does that make any sense right
this is this is the loop that we get
stuck in you're afraid of people not
seeing you and you're afraid of people
seeing you dude you like you can't win
the mental dialogue we have it with
ourselves we can't win
that's not possible
we need to start to flip that we need to
we need to rewire ourselves
and that starts again with being present
like you can't control what the outcome
is going to be in the future but you
can't control what you're doing right
now
if you can switch so that you are mostly
present
not really thinking about the past
unless it's gratitude right if you can
flip the regret of the past to gratitude
right and if you can switch the anxiety
for the future to excitement or vision
that's when you really start to win
somebody came to an event that I did in
Toronto and asked me these guys drove up
from Boston to do a podcast with me and
then stuck around for my event and they
asked me how much of your time do you
spend percentage-wise
living in the past present future
and I said zero percent passed
85 percent present
15 future
and the fifteen percent is
is Vision what I want to create you know
as entrepreneurs we have to be a little
bit forward-thinking but it's it's 85
present
I don't even know what day it is
like it's present not even present to
today but present to this moment I don't
know what day it is I don't know what
time it is
I know what I'm doing after this all I
know is I'm here right now with you guys
and that allows for Focus that allows
for happiness that allows for purpose
that allows for life to give you so many
gifts when you're not stuck living in
the past or the future
so how do you do it how do you how do
you get there
I think
the best thing you can do
is every time you catch yourself
drifting daydreaming forward or back in
a negative way
you catch it every time you can catch it
you won't catch it most of the time so
don't put this impossibly High burden on
yourself that every time I'm I'm
thinking about the past and I'm living
in regret I'm Gonna Catch and do
something about it you won't catch it
you won't catch it this is this is
Decades of un unwiring our brain right
it's fine don't don't have when you're
starting something new don't have crazy
expectations that you have to get it
perfect or you're a failure
right this is the problem not just with
this one exercise but with everything
don't expect to be great out of the gate
you won't you're just starting you're at
the beginning why do you think you're
going to be fantastic and because the
first time it doesn't work out perfectly
then we quit that is not how it works
right you you need to expect to suck at
the beginning that's okay
that's how you learn something every
time you can catch yourself drifting
you're you're living in a past in regret
or a future being stressed out just try
to bring it back to right now
just bring her back to the present and
focus on anything focus on a physical
object you can you could I could focus
on my coffee like how do I how can you
get present right now you focus on the
coffee wow look at this coffee cup you
know it's tall it's red I'm I'm grateful
for the beverage inside here uh I like
that they have sleep oh it's got a maple
leaf on it right like this is all I'm
being present right now with the cup of
coffee it is warm I can feel the
sensation on my hands
I can taste it in my mouth right
where most of the time even when you're
eating something most of the time when
you're eating something you're usually
focused on something else right you're
eating while you're on your phone you're
eating while you're watching a video
you're eating while you're doing
something now so not ever actually
enjoying the food because we're thinking
about what's next
so every time you can catch it you just
try to bring it back to the moment to
right now
and then what's going to happen is the
more you do that
the more you'll catch it
so right now maybe you're catch it one
percent of the time but the more you do
that and practice that and just pick one
thing to focus on that's in your
environment or focus on your breath
right it's why meditation works so well
with a mantra or breath work because it
gives you something to focus on when
you're first starting out with being
present and focused it's helpful to have
somewhere to put your attention because
focus on nothing doesn't feel like very
practical advice to the beginner trying
to figure this out so you focus on your
breath and anytime your mind wanders
bring her back to the breath every time
you get stressed or anxious or worried
or what you're going to do next bring it
back to the breath every time you get
bored
bring her back to the breath right the
breath could be anything the breath
could be the cup of coffee look at the
cup of coffee feel the cup of coffee
every time you get distracted you're
worrying about work or your life back to
the cup of coffee back to your Mantra
right all of that can work it's just
picking something to to ground you back
in being in the present
and again the more you catch it and the
more you do it the more you'll catch the
next one
and then while you're doing again the
next time
it's a skill that you learn you're
retraining your brain how to work
and what you'll find is the more you can
do that and the more you practice it
bit by bit
day by day
you'll find yourself
having less stress
being more productive
staying more focused
caring less about what other people
think about you
and overall being happier
and what that does is free you up to
actually go and do the work that's
inside you the genius that you've got
to put up to the world
and serve
being present
is the key to unlocking your happy life
less time living and regret about the
past less time living in the stress of
the future and anxiety for what may come
and more time focused on what can you do
right now
today in this moment
to be proud of yourself
and live your best life
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
when things are bad you feel bad so
there's dramatic contrast and polarity
and this is the realm of polarity right
so how do you find the middle path well
the heart is the middle path it's the
union of polarity it's the union of
opposites it's it's Oneness it's
homeless and this is where we have to
begin to create from all of this down
here is all Humanity this is all our
animal nature we get up and hear things
change right you go from selfish to
selfless if something else happens so
it's really funny too because when
a lot of people come they say I I don't
know I'm having difficulty opening my
heart I'm you know I'm practicing but
I'm not feeling anything yet and then it
comes time to do our healings on other
people and the moment you it was no
longer about you all sudden something
happened of course that's what the heart
is about right so so it comes in ways
that uh we we least expect at times
habit is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is The Sweet Spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts people
start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled they start
getting more afraid more anxious more
depressed and now the body is literally
being depleted of energy because it's
believing that it's living in an
emergency situation and an emergency you
tap all the body's resources for some
threat whether it's real or imagined and
so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool but the arousal that's
created from those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems and
the conditions in their life to reaffirm
their conditioning or their addiction to
that emotion and in a sense they become
addicted to the life they don't even
like and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay I'm not
going to say I can't I'm not going to
judge another person I'm not going to
blame I'm not going to complain I'm not
going to make excuses I'm not going to
be a victim I'm not going to talk trash
about anybody I'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the body's saying you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just gonna stop
today so now the body which has been
conditioned emotionally to be the Mind
wants to return back to its familiar
territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on this is a
good time to judge that come on this is
a good time to suffer it's your ex's
fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh you know it's
the weather what are the news whatever
it is and if we accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those Pharmacy of
chemicals and so that's when the person
makes the same Choice does the same
thing creates the same experience just
for that familiar feeling okay I'll
complain just so I can feel suffering
then they'd rather be unhappy than step
into the unknown well look I mean I
think that emotions are energy in motion
and so let's just say that um
we share the same experiences okay
Landon we're friends and we share the
same experience you're from London I've
been to London my daughter lives in
London and we have hey you do this I do
that you did that you know you own this
I own that you know so what we do is we
actually look to see when we meet people
if we're matching neurologically if
we're matching emotionally so if we
share the same experiences we share the
same emotions and if we share the same
emotions we can relate to one another so
this is where it gets sticky so then the
moment you start saying ah that person
did that to you once yeah that person I
had a similar experience that person's
that to me now now we open the door like
I'm gonna use you to reaffirm
my attachment to that emotion and let's
just work it up so that you can suffer
and I can suffer and then we can have a
conversation and literally we're sharing
the same energy and if we're sharing the
same energy we're sharing the same
information and we're Bound By An
Invisible field
of energy that keeps us connected yes so
then what does it take to break that
energetic field an energy that's greater
than the energy that's holding it
together that's how you separate atoms
that become a molecule you they're
they're Bound By An Invisible field of
energy that's keeping them connected so
you got to use a greater energy than the
energy that's holding them together to
separate them well in order for you to
change then you can't have energy
without awareness or Consciousness
you've got to go to a greater level of
Consciousness and change your energy and
nobody changes Jay until they change
their energy when they change their
energy they change their life so then
you may say well this person you know I
I use this person and I use my enemy to
reaffirm my addiction to hatred I use my
co-worker to reaffirm my addiction to
judgment I use my X to reaffirm my uh
addiction to resentment that we have
these different people in our lives that
we need to remind us of who we think we
are the enemy dies and you find another
one you know you know your co-worker uh
leaves and you start judging another one
it's just it's not any it's not that so
then
when there's no longer a vibrational
match
when you start doing the work and
there's no longer a vibrational match
with you and your past present reality
that that person or that condition any
longer
that person or condition is going to
spiral away because you're no longer
you're no longer in need of that so then
our life begins to change when we change
our energy and we begin to take our
power back That's essential for us to
begin to create with now some people can
handle that because
they're not conscious that they're doing
it so they'll be working on their vision
of their future and yet they'll spend
two hours lowering their energy back
into victimization or suffering and they
want to know why their future isn't
happening well there's an unconscious
program let's go after that and once you
start going after that now all of a
sudden your life starts to change again
so you can say it doesn't work on some
level we don't work and if you're really
invested in this
the question is what is it about me
where am I directing my attention or my
energy who am I using to reaffirm some
conditioning that I need to remember who
has my old self so then when you stop
reacting to the person or the person's
now complaining to you and you're not
complaining back
it's going to be an uncomfortable moment
because you're all of a sudden seeing a
part of you you used to be that you no
longer are and you have to be willing to
not go there and over time that person
will thank you and they'll say I didn't
even know that I was complaining that
much and by changing yourself you help
others stay conscious and not go
unconscious and it turns out that 95 of
the time we're unconscious so if you're
going to stay conscious then there's an
element that also requires a certain
amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so the thoughts that
they're thinking are slipping by their
awareness unnoticed because they're
hardwired in their brain because they've
been saying I can't it's too hard my
life will never change at someone else's
fault those thoughts have consequences
in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
becomes aware of how they speak and how
they act and they notice how they're
feeling they're no longer the program
they're the Consciousness outside the
program and that's the first step to
change so
there are there are when you when you're
distracted by your environment and you
got your cell phone and your tweeting
and your Instagraming and Facebook and
whatever people do you're distracted by
that feeling
but I now know that if you take a person
and you say Okay close your eyes sit in
the in the Silence of any external
stimulation remove the environment sit
your body down like an animal body is
the animal tell it to stay I'm gonna
feed you you can check your cell phone
you can shower you can have your coffee
but when I say
and so then Here Comes The Challenge
right so and and then if you say then
you're not going to live in The Familiar
future familiar past or predictable
future you're not going to think about
how long you've been meditating what you
got to do you you labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say I
think I'm meditating wrong I always say
oh no no you're doing it right because
when you notice that your body wants to
get up and check your cell phone or have
a cup of coffee and you become aware
that it's on autopilot and wants to do
that and you say come on over here and
you return it back to the present moment
you're executing a will now that's
greater than the program and if the
person wants to just get angry while
they're sitting there there's an arousal
and they notice the body is amping up
and revving up and they settle it back
down now they're telling the body it's
no longer the mind
the third of mine now we've researched
this
and it's tedious in the beginning at
first because David is fighting Goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner and later the body is trained to
a new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're they're working and lowering
the volume to that emotion the more they
lower the volume of that emotion the
more they're going to take their
attention off that person and problem
and they're going to take their power
back there's going to be a break and
their attention from that circumstance
and now they build their own field and
now there's energy to heal now there's
energy to create a new life now there's
energy for the mystical moment because
they've overcome their old personality
self so
I think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming overcoming overcoming
overcoming until we become somebody else
and when that occurs and the person
starts thinking differently and they
start acting differently and they start
feeling differently their new
personality and they they start seeing
those synchronicities and serendipities
how bad
does it have to get I mean to what
denominator to what lowest level do you
have to reach
before people really make up their mind
to change my message is why wait I mean
when you're feeling so altered
emotionally you feel so bad that's the
moment you could actually see yourself
for the first time because you're you're
not you're answering your cell phone
you're not responding to all your texts
you're not watching TV you're not going
out to dinners you're not calling people
back you're something's altered in you
and you're starting to become self-aware
right
so then people wait to that lowest
moment where they can start to see
themselves Through The Eyes of somebody
else well if you're waking up every day
and you're combining a clear intention
with an elevated emotion and you're
changing your emotional state to be
elevated you could still see the old
self from an elevated point of view and
be stay conscious then from a limited
point of view and that's what I want for
people like let's go I mean what do you
got to lose what people are going to
start wondering like did you change your
medication what's up with that guy
something's different about him you're
not predictable any longer right now we
say to our our community you know when
you're changing you just stop talking
about it you're just too busy being it
something's happening you know and
that's
the repetition of getting a few days in
a row of that really well I always say
God if you had a great meditation you
wake up feeling better at the end of
that meditation than when you started
and you do that the next day and then
the next day you're gonna start feeling
better all the time and that your body's
gonna start feeling better and
everything's gonna start feeling better
and you're going to start feeling better
about life so you ask a person why are
you so unhappy why are you so frustrated
why are you so resentful the moment you
ask that their brain is going to
associate that emotion to a past event
to a memory into a memory yeah that's
because they have nothing to look
forward to in their future so if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it just means to me that you're
more in love with your past than you are
with the future so how do you teach
people to believe in a future that they
can't see or experience with their
senses yet but they've thought about
enough times in their mind that their
brain is literally changed to look like
the event has already occurred the
latest research on Neuroscience says
that's absolutely possible we know that
and how do you teach a person
to select a new possibility in their
future and begin to emotionally Embrace
that future before it's made manifest to
such a degree that their body is their
unconscious mind is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're signaling new
genes in new ways ahead of the
environment now till their body begins
to change to look like the event has
already occurred we've proven that
that's possible now think about this so
the more you think about your desired
future The Joy the Gratitude the uh
the feelings you want to have that are
more positive the more you think about
it as it's as a future thing happening
the more your body shifts now exactly so
your body is believing it's living in
that future reality in the present
moment now think about this the stronger
the emotion you feel from some condition
in your life the more altered you feel
inside of you the more you narrow your
focus on the cause and the brain freezes
an image and takes a snapshot and that
memory now is embossed in the brain it's
branded in there so then people think
neurologically within the circuits of
those past experiences and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and the stronger the
Betrayal the stronger the trauma the
more the body's living in the past right
so then so how you reverse that so now
if you truly got passionate about a
future we've all done this you get a
wild idea in your mind and you start
holding on to that vision and you're
preoccupied with it all of a sudden the
thought in your mind becomes the
experience and you start feeling the the
energy of the future now the stronger
the emotion you feel from that Vision
the more you're going to pay attention
to the picture in your mind and now
you're remembering your future vice
versa the stronger you pay attention to
the feeling of the past pain you're
going to create the pain in this moment
exactly so then so it requires a
coherent brain and we now know that
there's a formula for that and we've got
beautiful research to show that people
can do it they just have to practice and
it requires a coherent heart because
resentment frustration in patience
creates a very incoherent heart yeah and
when that heart becomes incoherent you
stop trusting yourself there's no energy
you stop trusting in your future so then
if there's physical evidence in your
brain and body
physical evidence to look like the event
has already occurred it's quite possible
you'll be thinking neurologically within
the circuits of your future and you'll
begin to feel chemically within the
boundaries of that emotion of your
future and how you think and how you
feel is your state of being and now your
state of being is living in the future
instead of the past now
the moment you disconnect from the
emotion of your future because traffic
or some co-worker or your ex or whatever
people come up with now you're back to
the energy of your past and now you're
going to start looking for it analyzing
why hasn't it happened well if you're
feeling the emotion of your future why
would you look for it because you would
feel like it already happened and that
is the place where the magic happens so
then you can't just do this get up and
then return back to your old state of
being
you got to maintain that modified
statement when life happens well let me
finish I watch with a face right now how
do you make well of course of course I
mean we all take blows in our lives and
and we all react emotionally but the
question is
how long are you gonna read right right
so then if you can't mediate and
regulate your emotional reactions and
those emotions linger for days that's
years for some people mood and then a
month's temperament years personality
trait so then the person's personality
is literally based on the past but they
don't know that because they're doing it
over and over again it becomes a
subconscious program so now if requires
a coherent brain and a coherent heart
then we have to train people how to
self-regulate what kind of attention and
intention do you want a place so that
that becomes the loudest voice in your
head and if you keep practicing it the
hardware becomes a software program and
it'll say Jay you can do anything Jay
you live in no time and accomplish
everything Jay
you're unlimited you just gotta hang
with it on the other side of this is
greatness whatever you want to program
in there you get the program in there if
you sat down and say how am I going to
be with my wife my husband my partner
how I'm going to be with my kids I'm
going to be at work with my co-workers
how am I going to be in traffic
and you close your eyes and you begin to
rehearse in your mind if you're truly
present the brain does not know the
difference between the real life
experience and what you're imagining so
now the brain goes from a record of the
past to a map to the Future now you're
installing the hardware keep practicing
it it becomes automatic comes easier now
it's a software program you may just
start behaving differently in order for
you to to Really begin to explore the
unknown aspect of yourself you got to
learn how to get beyond the known aspect
of yourself and if you keep coming back
to the known you're going to miss out on
the unknown so you would say well I
don't know anything in the unknown of
course it's the unknown and if you try
to control it there you're back to the
known if you try to predict that you're
back to the known so you got to go
through this trial and error of just
kind of refining your attention refining
your ability and and it's just got to be
something like playing tennis or playing
golf or doing martial arts or working
out or crocheting or stance in the salsa
you just got to keep going man in the
beginning it's tedious and then when you
start finding your groove like our our
community
they don't miss their morning
meditations yeah you know why because
the magic is happening and they know if
they miss it they're gonna they're gonna
cut off from the magic some they whether
they're tired whether they're hungover
whether they're what they're right
they're in right you know and if you if
you wake up in the morning
and you can't get your butt out of bed
you know what that means it just means
you can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
your life your body's resigned so then
so then you know when you went on a
school trip when you were a kid you know
you woke up before your parents yes you
knew something new was going to happen
that's the body going wake up wake up
it's something unexpected is going to
happen what happened to us Christmas day
yes
so why not yeah you know put in your put
in your time and then and then measure
the effects of you would cause I mean
become a scientist in your life and
really start to experiment with it okay
let me change my energy let me just
write down four thoughts that like I can
it's too hard I'll start tomorrow this
doesn't feel right whatever it is it's
be this person's fault just write those
down and say these thoughts like Gandalf
on the bridge yes you may not pass today
this is the end yes so then if you
become conscious of those thoughts now
you're the governor of your thoughts
what what what actions what behaviors do
you want to change do you complain you
blame you judge do you make excuses how
do you talk do you speak limited just
pick four things that you're not gonna
do any longer yeah what emotions get you
in trouble what are the emotions that
you're addicted to too right that you're
addicted to that keep you returning back
to your past if you don't know close
your eyes for about 30 minutes and just
watch where your mind goes and watch
your feelings and just say okay it's
frustration it's unworthiness it's
self-doubt it's guilt it's frustration
it's shame just become conscious of
those and just review them in your mind
so that you don't go unconscious them in
your waking day we have a thousand
reasons I have more than a thousand
Reasons every day to be unhappy with
managing companies and staff and people
all that but but then when you rise
above that and you choose just who you
want to be
uh I think it makes a big impression uh
on your on your family first yourself
your family and your friends and the
people you work with and then finally
our communities so I think that people
are starting to figure that out there
and and when they imagine oxytocin
levels in our student body
the love hormone the love chemical 200
times outside of normal the latest
research on oxytocin is slight slight
elevation on oxytocin it's impossible to
hold a grudge now so then what that
means is you feel
so amazing that why would you want to
hold a grudge against that person so
forgiveness then is not something that
you have to try to do to be spiritual
it's the side effect of saying I don't
want to give up this feeling for you or
anybody so I'm letting it go I'm freeing
you I'm freeing myself and my goodness
there's more liberation of energy I call
that the natural state of being and
we're knocking on that door why
because as you begin to open your heart
to life again and you start trusting in
your future and trusting in yourself a
little bit more and you start
self-regulating with your heart
you do that properly and you lead from
that place from that level of awareness
your life will change in dramatic ways
and why is that essential because when
people start doing that effectively
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals a chemical called
endothelial derived relaxing factor and
that causes the arteries in your heart
and lungs Jay to literally swell just
like when you're
when your sexual organs are aroused and
blood flow moves into them male and
female that's a different Consciousness
there's a different energy in there
imagine the same intensity moving into
your heart that's what people are
experiencing that is a level of love
that's not like a love for your puppy
it's not like the love for your partner
this is transcendent of that this is the
most familiar unfamiliar feeling you
will ever have it'll be distant and at
the same time very close and you'll
start to see the hidden meaning behind
all things and now when you walk in the
presence of your greatest betrayer
the person who threw you under the bus
whatever it is when you walk in from
this place there will be no emotional
reaction you will just see that person
for who they are who you used to be no
compassion then is no longer something
that you have to try to do it's the end
product of doing the work and I think
that Mystics and Saints and masters of
old understood this
so when they thought of that person
they didn't allow that thought to
produce a feeling or an energy that
would lower their energy they understood
that when they had the thought of that
person they saw their limitation it
wasn't hurting them it was only hurting
themselves now I think that the world
was doing that wow we'd have a very
different world thoughts to me produce
an electrical charge in the quantum
field and feelings produce a magnetic
charge in the quantum field that's wait
thoughts produce a what an electrical
charge okay and feelings produce a
magnetic charge and how you think and
how you feel broadcasts an
electromagnetic signature that
influences every single atom in your
life the thought sends the signal out
now think about this and the feeling
draws the event back so you could have
the intent that you want wealth you want
Health you want success that's your
intent that's your thought but if you're
waiting for the experience to happen to
feel it then you're not drawing the
experience to you because you're not
feeling the emotion right so then
teaching people once again how to
balance their thoughts and feelings
because you can you can enter that cycle
either place sometimes we do a
meditation
we start opening our heart we start
elevating the body's energy and then
those emotions can drive certain
thoughts of your future other times you
open your awareness you create brain
coherence you have the vision of your
future you begin to emotionally
experience it however you want to jump
on that cycle and then sustain it
because the longer you're conscious of
that energy the more you're drawing your
future to you so then most people spend
their lives right
they we live in this realm called
space-time three-dimensional reality and
you move your body through space in
three-dimensional reality it takes time
yeah so everything all your goals all
your dreams all your Visions you're
going to have to get your body up and
drag it through space every day to pay
off that you know that home that's in
your future right right when you create
from the field instead of from matter
when there's a vibrational match between
your energy and some potential and your
thoughts and feelings are coherent now
you are going to begin to collapse time
and space or the experience is going to
be drawn to you now now you're the
vortex to your destiny and now you don't
have to go anywhere to get it because
you're not playing by the rules of
three-dimensional reality you're playing
by the rules of energy in the quantum if
the word meditation means become
familiar with right
then you know people say oh well you
shouldn't focus on the negative well
really that's 95 of who you are and you
got to begin to dismantle or denature
that old personality and that means
you're going to have to come up against
the Cravings that the body has
emotionally you know like it is it's
eight o'clock in the morning and you're
doing your meditation you're normally in
traffic and you want to get angry and
your body's going hey you're off
schedule so let me just find something
that's mapped in the brain that I I'll
bring up a past experience why you can
feel a little anger well now once you're
become aware of that now now the game is
on right because now you're working to
become conscious of that and not go
unconscious again and it takes an
incredible amount of awareness yes it
takes a great amount of Consciousness
and you can have Consciousness without
energy so you got to raise your energy
in order to get to otherwise you're
going to be consumed yes you're going to
return back right so
gosh so if you start becoming familiar
so conscious of those unconscious
thoughts they would never slip by your
mind and check by you now that is when
you really catch yourself right and the
research shows that you can get better
at this you could actually sense the
thought before it comes so then you
start firing and wiring new thoughts you
start thinking to yourself who am I
going to be when I open my eyes well how
am I gonna how am I going to make a
difference in the world today who am I
going to be how am I going to love how
am I going to give how am I going to
serve how am I going to contribute what
things do I want to really do today and
in the in the act of closing your eyes
and just thinking about and rehearsing
what you're going to do your brain
doesn't know the difference and if you
get caught up in it
you begin to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to look like
you've already done it done it now the
brain is no longer a record of the past
now it's a map to the Future you are
priming your brain and if you keep doing
it yes the hardware will become a
software program you know what that
means you just might start acting like a
happy person well there's no surprise
there you install the circuits stress
hormones arouse the body so you have
your attention on your body stress
hormones alert the brain so you're aware
of everything in your environment like
an octopus with tentacles in all
different directions you got to control
and predict everything in your life and
if you're living by the hormones of
stress you're always investing your
attention and energy into the known
future based on the past so you want to
you're on a you're on a line of time
here on a timeline so then let's think
about it how are you going to make
thought more real than anything else how
are you going to create from thought
well let's close our eyes
let's disconnect from the environment
right less sensory information coming
into the brain less distraction as you
said let's play some soft music in the
background let's stick some earplugs in
order whatever you want to do diminish
sensory but now you're sitting down
you're not eating you're not tasting
you're not smelling you're not feeling
so there's more less less sensory input
coming to your body so then now your
brain waves begin to change they start
slowing down and you move from this beta
brainwave pattern where you're aware
that you have a body in space and time
or your attention is on the outer world
or your senses are giving you
information less sensory information now
your inner world starts becoming more
real than the outer world and you're not
the voice in your head that's always
talking to you as your brain waves
change you start seeing in images and
pictures and symbols and less in that
vocalization that subvocalization so
your brain waves start changing the
alpha you're going to start creating
start dreaming pretending right so then
if you say to your body
you're going to sit down for an hour and
I know you're on a program because you
wake up every morning and do the exact
same thing and now I'm going to make you
sit just like sent to an animal you sit
you stay and your body's gonna say I'm
gonna die my bladder is going to explode
I need a coffee I got a lot of emails to
do that's the program and you say to
your body
today we do battle today this is it and
you sit through that and you make your
way even though your body's trying to
get up and you keep settling it back
down I'm telling you when you start your
day that day you will be more kind more
loving less judgmental more patient more
present because you're mastering the
present moment that means you're not in
the predictable future you're not in the
familiar past you're mastering time and
so then if where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
and all of your attention is in the
present moment
it's got a lot of energy to do amazing
things and you know when someone's
present with you in your life because
they're paying attention to you and you
know when they're not present because
they're not paying attention to yourself
so the act of getting more present means
you're putting a lot of energy in the
present moment and you're taking your
power back from all these things and
people in your life so
we teach people this
as they start breaking through and they
start being able to unfold into this
field as an awareness and they're not
putting their attention on their boss or
their ex or their wife or their kids or
their cell phone or their WhatsApp or
their Facebook
they're they're they're they're they're
they're not thinking at all so then as
they're sensing the space they can't
think and if you can't think you can't
analyze and if you can't analyze the
analytical mind is what separates the
conscious mind from the subconscious you
just open the door wow and so now wow
you can reprogram and if you could give
everyone in the world an experiment to
do for 30 days one activity that they'd
have to do every day for 30 days what
would it be oh I would ask them to take
out a piece of paper and write down
every thought that they've been thinking
that standing in the way between their
future and and where they are to write
down every habit or behavior even how
they speak that stops them from becoming
the person that is healthy wealthy or
free and then to begin to uh recognize
the emotions
that keep them in the same state of
being every single day and become so
conscious of those thoughts behaviors
and emotions that they wouldn't let any
any of them slip by unnoticed by them
then I would have them write down the
thoughts they do want to fire and wire
in their brain I would have them write
down what the behaviors look like of a
great person that they wanted to become
and I would have them practice thinking
about it and practice rehearsing it and
then I would say to them
what emotions would you feel when your
future happened because you have to
teach your body emotionally what that
future feels like before it happens and
every day if you practice that
diligently and sincerely and just become
conscious of who you no longer want to
be and keep becoming conscious of who do
you do want to be you should begin to
see evidence in your life and when it
comes in a way that you least expect
that surprises you and leaves no doubt
that it's come from a greater mind then
you'll be inspired to do it again and
now we believe we're more of the
creators of our lives and if you said
well listen I'm not going to wait for my
healing
to feel gratitude I'm not going to wait
for my new relationship to feel love
I'm gonna actually teach my body
emotionally what that future feels like
before it happens now
this is a big turnaround for a lot of
people because we're so reliant on the
outer World to Change our inner world
right waiting and postpone waiting is
not creating I mean period And when
people are they could have the greatest
intentions in the world
but if they don't combine that with an
elevated emotion there's no signal
because the elevated emotion is the
carrier it's the energy that carries the
thought
so then when we're in separation in lack
waiting for our wealth to feel abundance
we're basically living our whole life in
pain right so then if you reason this
and a person can get up from their
meditation and they literally feel
differently and they're feeling the
emotions of their future before it
happens this is turning the the whole
process around
they can't be looking for it why would
they be looking for it if they felt like
it there it already happened now there's
no separation now this is when those
serendipities and coincidences and
opportunities begin to show up in
people's lives so it's work
but then when they start seeing the
experience in their life
all of a sudden they start believing
they're more of the creator of their
life yeah and less of a victim of their
life a community of like-minded like
like similar energy of people uh
everybody understands they get one
another you know you you communities
tends to be the thing now that in terms
of our social media and the feedback
we're getting everybody wants more
Community because you get a you get a
thousand people in an audience and their
energy synchronized now you're thinking
of something so much bigger we're just
going to measure this I just talked to a
researcher yesterday we're going to
measure a thousand people when they
reach that synchronized moment when
they're we can we know that the entire
social coherence in the room is orderly
then if you're producing a ambient
coherent magnetic field in your heart
and you're tuning into a thought or an
intent and you got a thousand people
doing that and your energy is going to
start interfering and mingling with the
persons next to you when that energy
starts to synchronize it's going to
produce a bigger wave the higher the
amplitude the higher the wave the more
energy there is so now you have one mind
and one heart and now when it comes to
Healing others and we've done the
research on this now and we're
collecting the data that we're teaching
people how to administer
a change in energy in a person that's
laying there because it's not matter
that emits a field that's the wrong way
to think about it it's the field that
creates matter
you change the field you change matter
you're not it's not your job to change
the tumor the tumor is the illusion it's
the pattern in the field that's that
that has to be changed so once people
start reversing this then you start
seeing tumors disappearing you start
seeing blind people seeing deaf people
hearing you start seeing people with
Parkinson's disease switch on I mean you
start seeing
stage four cancer is reversing because
now they're you're you're you're
swimming Upstream you're going to the
headwaters and making that change it's
so important in that of the infinite
places you can put your attention
put it on your heart now when you place
your attention is where you place your
energy why because we want this Center
to bloom
1400 1300 different chemicals that
restore and regenerate the body let's
breathe let's open this up let's
practice this let's start learn how to
lead with our heart a different
Consciousness yeah in the beginning
it's a little difficult but you stay
with it and you practice it pedal by
pedal by pedal placing your attention
there you're putting your own life force
back into your heart you're turning your
love Inward and the body will start
responding and in a week's time if we're
doing that three times a day or over and
over again
sooner or later that thing's going to
start blooming and just like when your
sexual organs are aroused and they're
engorged with blood this Center when you
start feeling love you make a chemical
called oxytocin
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals a chemical called derived
endothelial relaxing Factor you know
what that is it causes the arteries in
your heart to literally open up so your
heart is going to be filled with blood
and oxygen and nutrients it's
physiological it's going to feel full
you're going to have a hard on in a
sense your heart is going to heal right
and when that happens
you experience a level of love
that passes all understanding you your
cup runneth over I mean it is and people
are in they're sobbing because they
realize that this this Center finally
like a child I think we're all faced
with great opportunities brilliantly
disguised as impossible situations and
in order like for me personally and I
and after looking through your book and
reading a good portion of it I mean for
me there's there's no school of ancient
wisdom that you need to go to be
initiated your life is your initiation
if you're paying attention so we meet
challenges in our life from a certain
level of mind right a certain level of
Consciousness or unconsciousness and
even Einstein said we have to go to a
greater level of consciousness
uh then the Consciousness that's created
the problem well what is consciousness
Consciousness is awareness and awareness
means possibilities that you haven't
thought of before so we could we
confront problems or challenges in our
life and as a side note I was having
breakfast with a researcher just last
week who's studying what happens when we
perceive and condition in our
environment as a problem how it weakens
the organism they're measuring this and
when a person sees it as a challenge how
they draw energy they raise the energy
of their body back into order
so if we said I want to be
wealthy or I want to be healthy
well what what you want to be that
because you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're going to have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that I am feeling about that
circumstance and that feeling is causing
me to think about it so you say oh it's
impossible they'll never change I'll
hire a hitman I'll hire the mafia I'll
hire an attorney I'll hit my friend's
friend to talk to him and nothing
changes right well
you're not you're not separate from that
experience you're involved in it and how
you think and how you feel broadcasts
energy into the field so your energy is
the same every day and as long as your
energy is the same nothing's going to
change in your life either and nobody
changes until they change their energy
so then
what piece of knowledge what piece of
information what would love do what
would greatness look like okay I don't
know all right well certainly somebody
in history has faced this problem
don't get on Facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get go
look it up and study and breed and learn
you'll own it and you'll say wow that
person that was wealthy
they failed 500 times well hell I had
the wrong view of wealth okay then
failure is not a thing I gotta overcome
failure well yep just climb the step
yeah okay I'm reacting to that
circumstance with the same emotion that
emotion is firing the same thoughts I'm
broadcasting the same energy into the
field if I were facing that circumstance
and situation again with that person
that circumstance what do I learn from
that circumstance how could I do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install the circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
Consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you're unconscious now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stop forgetting and when we get
to that point now we're conscious now
there's wisdom and wisdom is the memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person that
what now now you don't create your
reality you only create your reality
when things are good no well somehow you
got to Tango through this somehow your
objectivity in not reacting emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation Consciousness is
awareness awareness is paying attention
and noticing and so 95 of Who We Are by
the time we're 35 years old is a set of
unconscious automatic programs that
we've just practiced so many times that
we're not consciously thinking about
those so in order for you to change to
answer the initial question that you
asked
the first step is you got to become
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
and you gotta you gotta start looking at
those hard-wired thoughts that that you
think every day that are just circuits
that have been fired and wired together
how do we do that should we write a list
at the end of the day or one of the most
common thoughts we have that day like
how does someone become aware you don't
have to do that you just have to sit
down close your eyes and not move and
then you'll get you'll you'll start
seeing what am I thinking about right
now yeah and all you want to do is
observe the thought because
when you begin to observe that thought
you're no longer the program now you're
the Consciousness observing the program
and you're starting to pull out of the
program thinking about the thinking yeah
who's doing the thinking of the thinking
about the thinking that's who you are
when you're not the program that's
awareness right yeah you got to become
aware of how you speak how you act
becomes so conscious
so aware of it that you won't go
unconscious and let that thought or that
behavior run you you gotta say oh my God
this feeling that I've been living by
for the last 20 years is actually guilt
I didn't know it was guilt because it
just feels like me and all of a sudden
as you start becoming conscious of it
you're beginning to objectify your
subjective self you're you're pulling
out of those programs and nobody likes
to do that because it's uncomfortable
they'd rather turn on their cell phone
start texting get on the internet you
know watch TV to distract them from that
moment and that is what they have to
move through in order to get to their to
their own personal freedom so the first
step is becoming conscious and
meditation means to become familiar with
to become conscious of to to become so
conscious of your unconscious self that
you won't go unconscious to any thought
any Behavior or emotion and get ready
because it takes a tremendous amount of
energy
to do that and awareness stay conscious
to stay conscious and so
we fall from grace yeah fine you got it
you got you're awake you got another day
let's go again how often do you fall oh
my gosh I mean how many times have I
done it thousands but I'm not gonna give
up because the moments in which I do
connect or the moments that I do have
that transcendental experience
what matters the most after it when I
have that transcendental moment I look
back
and all of those difficult meditations
those difficult days and those are the
ones you remember you don't remember the
good meditations you remember the ones
where you came up against yourself and
you went a little further and you said
I'm gonna go a little further and go a
little further or you had a rough day
and you just went in and you just you at
the end of the day you surrender and you
have the classic Oh My God moment
there's no linear correlation it's just
whether you're willing to live in
creation instead of living in survival
and so
um you get better at it you know we just
get better at it and for me
um staying conscious and staying where
and staying present
is an art because you you know when
someone's present with you in your life
because they're paying attention to you
you know when they're not present with
you because they're not paying attention
to you so imagine this field of
information this this intelligence that
lives within you and I that's governing
everything material in this world it's a
self-organizing intelligence
you have access to it so you better get
present with it as well as you can get
present with anything else and just
because you can't see it doesn't mean it
doesn't exist right and that that that
realm you can't experience with your
senses you can only experience with your
awareness so then people have to take
their attention off their bodies and go
from a somebody to a nobody take their
attention off the people in their life
and go from that they identify with and
go from a someone to a no one take their
attention off the things in their life
their cell phone their computer their
car and go from something to nothing
take their attention off where they
sleep where they work where they're
sitting and go from somewhere to Nowhere
take their attention off the predictable
future and the familiar past and time
and go from some time to no time and now
if you're taking all of your attention
off of everything material in this
three-dimensional reality now there's
only one other thing that's left that
means you're an awareness your
Consciousness and now that is the bridge
that is the door to the quantum field
and you can't enter the quantum field as
a somebody so if someone has spent their
whole life working on having the perfect
body or so much so they have so much
attention on their pain where you place
your attentions where you place your
energy it's going to take some work for
them to take all of their attention off
their body right because they'll go
they'll do it and then they'll go back
let's see if the Pain's still there oh
the Pain's still there so it's a little
bit of a waltz in the beginning but as
people start applying this you start
getting better at it let's demystify
meditation because it has so many
stigmas around it close your eyes
Retreat from your life disconnect from
your body disconnect from your
environment disconnect from your
schedule and just give yourself an hour
or 45 minutes or 20 minutes because when
you invest in yourself you invest in
your future and when you believe in
yourself you believe in possibilities
and when you believe in possibilities
you believe in yourself and if you don't
believe in possibilities then you don't
believe in yourself and you don't
believe in yourself if you don't believe
in possibilities so then but if you have
a community a living organism yeah where
it's becoming The New Normal yes you
want to join that living organism and
you want to you want to be a part of
that and and every every stride you make
feeds the living organism every stride
every effort you make uh to connect is
is amazing because that which we are
seeking is seeking us it's not like it
is it matches our efforts and so then
when when people have that
uncompromising will the same way that
they go shopping for a dress or a pair
of earrings or go to the gym and work
out with the same intensity with the
same passion come up against themselves
and just say when the body's going given
everything it has it's when you say
that's all you got that's it that's all
you're going to put out to where I'm
ready and so then
when you start overcoming that the side
effect of it is that all of a sudden
you're happy for no reason and you're
less seduced in believing that something
else you need something outside of it
outside of you to make you feel better
all of a sudden you're feeling better
every day without anything outside of
you and now all of a sudden you start
showing up unpredictable in your life
you're saying that Ed guy he's different
he's a different medications
but in actuality you're just Freer right
and so so then as we begin to remove
these layers that stop the flow of the
Divine in us that that in essence in us
the side effect is we become more
willful become more mindful become more
conscious we become more loving it's
it's its nature you know it's just it
just it comes becomes who we are at the
end of the day if you really wanted to
be wealthy say
how did I do today did I make the right
choices what was I ethical was I Purpose
Driven was I was I was I interested in
making a difference was I fair was I
tempered did I really think before I
spoke what what did I remember reading
about that book about that person that
did it how'd I do and if you said I when
did I fall from grace when did I lose it
okay I want that opportunity again
I want another shot at that and I'm
going in this way what would love do in
this situation what would greatness do
and now you you evolve your experience
and somehow there's a door there's an
opening something shifts something's
changing and now here we go we climb
another ladder and then all of a sudden
there's another challenge and then
people who finally arrive at their
abundance they could care less if
they're abundant they're already knowing
that they've earned the right for it so
so there's sometimes a shortcut in the
process if we're if we really learn and
we really get it but the trial and error
is so important because
not only is the person earning the right
to be wealthy but they're earning the
right to live in worthiness worthy to
receive like hey you people people come
to our work all the time for a lot of
reasons and one of the common reasons is
they want to get healthy yeah and and
they're ill because they're dealing with
a very serious health condition and I
always say the same thing to them
stop wanting to be healthy learn the
formula yeah on how to get healthy learn
the formula on how to heal and the
healing will be the side effect of it if
you're obsessing about why am I not
healed you're still the old person you
could become that person every day right
turns out that when you sit down
and the people that we interview that
have had significant changes
when it's no longer about their health
but they are they are out of the
bleachers and they're on the playing
field and they are coming up against the
belief like one lady said God I I always
thought that this work really worked
that this these concepts are the truth
but I never believed it worked for me
and I was in a car accident I'm in a
wheelchair and then she made the
decision that she was going to overcome
that belief now it was no longer about
her healing it was about overcoming the
belief which overcame the belief and I
showed up every day for herself when you
believe in yourself you believe in
possibilities When You Believe in
possibilities you got to believe in
yourself you don't show up for yourself
you don't believe in it yeah and and
that's why people don't do the work I
mean if you you believe that your
thoughts create a reality you would show
up every day and create and so a lot of
people believe in their past more than
they believe in their future a lot of
people fall in love or more in love with
their past or romance their past instead
of romance their future or love their
future it's it's that simple so
the initiation process of life is always
going to be there you're always going to
be challenged if if you want to be a
master well then you better learn how to
heal someone else and you're going to
fail a lot of times and if you think
that you're a failure then you'll quit
but if you feel like you just didn't
quite ding it yet and you show up again
to just ding it and you keep evolving
your experience and go deeper how much
more can I open my heart how much more
can I Surrender into this infinite field
how much more can I become can I walk as
it with my eyes open people do
meditations and they have great
meditations me included and then you get
up you open your eyes and you're back in
the program and people want to know why
they haven't healed and we have
testimonies of people they're speaking
the truth they said my Ms my rheumatoid
and my lupus never went away
and I had great meditations I felt
better
and then I realized with my eyes open I
was still that person and now
Next Level they're in the game and
catching themselves or catching how they
speak they're watching how they think
they're not letting their body fall in
the same emotional state to put them in
the same past experience that the body's
believing in now this is the this is the
great part and when a person finally
breaks through from the chains
and there's a different consciousness of
Freedom that happens they look back at
their past they want to change one thing
in their past because it brought them to
that present moment that's the path no
longer existing that's the freedom so is
it worth the effort yeah it's no longer
about healing it's no longer about
abundance it's about who you're becoming
I will never work in a relationship I
just won't if I'm working in a
relationship something's wrong I work on
me and I'll bring my best you bring your
best and we get together and we
celebrate it should work it should work
and if it doesn't then I'm gonna step
back and see what is it about me not you
what is it about me that I need to
really look at and change now if there's
a vibrational match and it flows and
it's fun and you connect on
physically mentally Mind Body Soul you
know that's cool I think that's healthy
but a mission-driven person can't be in
a relationship where you have to keep
going back
and and trying to fix something I just I
just won't do that I just think that
when it when it's right it's right and
I'll know
yeah yeah so I think that I do think
that uh
relationships can be easy and I I do
think I I and I think that they should
be and I and I think that if you're
heart centered that's a different place
you meet uh than than other emotions and
and I and I and again every time I have
a mystical moment
and I feel that transcendental love that
I don't even know the word for uh every
time I have one of those moments I think
I got this all wrong it's just that it's
it is not chemical it's electric and you
got what all wrong well the way we view
the world the way we pres I mean we
don't see things how they are we see
things how we are you know in every
inner experience that's transcendental
experience and riches circuitry in your
brain experience produces emotion or
energy in the body so you start having
transcendental moments where you start
connecting to that field its signature
is love I mean but not love like a love
for your puppy it's this is like this is
like an arousal this is I don't know the
other word but spiritual arousal yeah
and we have the we have the evidence we
can say oh watch this watch this
person's brain and scientists are
studying our work I'll say oh um watch
she's gonna pop in a few minutes and
what do you mean just watch she's gonna
pop and all of a sudden this person goes
into into an arousal the sympathetic
nervous system is so switched on but the
arousal isn't like an arousal that from
the environment that produces anger or
aggression or fear anxiety or pain or
suffering that's that's Survival in the
environment that produces the URL this
arousal is coming from energy in the
body that's moving up into the brain and
the arousal is bliss the arousal is
ecstasy the arousal is freedom but it's
it's not chemical it's it's you'll feel
it in every single cell in your body now
here's the outcome of that
the outcome of that is that when you
open your eyes
and some conditioning some layer has
been removed
your spectrum of the way the world looks
and broadens now because now you're
wired to perceive what's always existed
but you didn't have the circuits in
place to perceive them so then it's the
inner experience that literally trans
transforms our experience of the outer
world and so when you start having
moments where you hit that kind of
frequency or you have those moments of
love
you're less dependent on anyone to bring
you happiness you're you're okay you can
love the person for their flaws because
you can see a part of yourself you used
to be that you no longer aren't instead
of judgment you have compassion and you
can encourage and and and communicate
from a from a level of connection
instead of intimidation or or
competition or however relationships
work the person's doing the vision board
and they're saying when I get my new car
I get my new house I get my new
relationship then I'm gonna feel so
great now that well then they're back to
the program waiting for it to happen for
them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no effect of drawing the
experience to you with that way
so the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process and you feel grateful
you feel A Love For Life you feel a joy
for existence you feel a passion to for
the moment
uh you will not be looking for your
future because you'll feel like it's
already happened it's the moment that we
start feeling those self-limiting
emotions that we feel separation and
then we start looking for it again well
then if you're waiting you're not
creating your you're in separation again
so then yeah so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being thoughts are the vocabulary of the
brain feelings are the vocabulary of
your body how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being so then if
you wake up in the morning and you come
come back to your senses with a clean
slate and you say I don't feel anything
and you say well let me start thinking
about all the problems in my life well
all those problems are connected to
different people or different objects of
things at different times and places the
moment you remember your problems a
memory is a record of the past you're
thinking in the past every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
them so all of a sudden you start
feeling unhappy you start feeling bitter
you start feeling frustrated so I know
your body's in the past so then most
people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to Crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine so then we want
people then to get very clear on that
vision of their future however they do
it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel from
the vision they're creating the more
altered they feel inside of them the
more they're going to pay attention to
the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment where you have that feeling
that's your compass because that feeling
is going to drive your behaviors it's
going to drive more of those thoughts
and when you feel that feeling and it's
visceral
no person no thing no experience will
stand in the way between you and that
vision and and you will be initiated in
by the universe into wealth you will be
initiated into Health you'll be
initiated into Freedom those people all
those people that have healed themselves
of all those different health conditions
they are so humble and so happy and they
feel so great that they would never
trade this feeling because of what you
thought of them they they've they've
left that program behind a long time ago
they actually don't care how you think
of them they they actually are so happy
with themselves that they're no longer
dependent on anything outside of them
now I think that's a really important
moment because that's the moment we give
people permission in our lives to do the
same right and I think that more and
more people are beginning to figure that
out one of the things about the global
pandemic that I said to my staff and to
my family the moment I heard how the
circumstances in the world changed I
just said I refuse to be a victim to
these circumstances so a victim
Consciousness is when we allow something
in our outer environment to control the
way we feel and think so if I say to you
Jay why are you so upset today and you
said oh it's because of this person or
circumstance what you're really saying
is something in my outer environment
some person or some condition is
controlling the way I think and feel now
that's not the truth that's just a
response right
so anything that controls our thoughts
and feelings causes us to be victim to
those things and the stronger the
emotion we feel to some circumstance in
our life the more we pay attention to it
and where we place our attention is
where we place our energy so we're
giving our life force we're giving our
power away to that circumstance and so I
just made up my mind that it was a great
opportunity to get into the Cocoon if
you want to another Amazing Joe dispenza
clip check it out right there next to me
I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there